[Música]
olá meu nome é joão tem dez anos e isso
nunca 5º ano
hoje vou falar sobre uma grande história
de superação uma história de vida
emocionante a do maestro joão carlos
martins tem várias razões para escolher
esse tema a primeira é que adoro música
e de algum instrumento
a segunda é que já vi ele tocar aqui no
colégio a terceira é que vissem o filme
fiquei impressionado
assim como ele eu também passei pra mim
isto é de superação quando tinha oito
anos tivesse obtido no barreiro que é o
baixio do be que você paralisa todo o
seu corpo - de sua respiração
joão carlos martins aprendeu a tocar
pelo desde cedo incentivado pelo seu pai
com oito anos de idade já tocava bem ele
chegava a tocar até 12 horas por dia em
busca da perfeição ele era um exímio
tocador de bassuma e um dos seus
melhores intérpretes sem dúvida um dos
melhores jogadores do mundo
a experiência do mundo quando já famoso
e vivendo em nova york viu o time da
portuguesa tem dano e que jogar bola com
eles neste jogo caiu ea troféu três
dedos de sua mão direita
ele tocou por vários anos com sua mão
doendo e atrofiada até uma apresentação
em berlim e seus desejos de sua mão
direita de wilson grava entendo que
chegou até uma embolia pulmonar o
terminá la
para piorar sua situação no ano de 2000
sua mão esquerda também começou
atrofiaram mas gostaria de conhecer
vocês como ele foi superando cada
dificuldade que enfrentava ele colocou
uma prótese dos dedos da mão direita
para ajudar o seu carro melhor mas mesmo
assim doía muito
quando os desde sua mão direita não
permitindo que ele tocasse mais passou a
estudar o concerto de pedro para boa
esquerda de ravel ele até chegou a fazer
uma turnê mundial com este concerto
quando as duas mãos não permitiu que ele
tocasse mais
ele desistiu e resolveu investir tudo e
parar de tocar pena mas com 63 anos ele
teve uma grande superação e que aprender
a região que estas e é ser o maestro só
seu sucesso foi tanto que chegou a reger
a orquestra de câmara de londres uma das
mais famosas do mundo
ainda hoje ele é maestro de trabalho com
o pessoal da nossa comunidade foi uma
jovem talento para música
agora vamos ouvir um trecho dele regendo
será que vocês já conhecem sua busca
[Música]
é
esse foi o hino da champions league bom
lembrá lá no comecinho
quando eu disse que tocava o instrumento
e se ele o clarinete vem essa história
me parece um grande exemplo de superação
mostra que não há limites para quem quer
superar suas dificuldades
portanto nunca devemos desistir de
nossos sonhos obrigado
[Aplausos]